there are many valid criticisms of the
recent Thanksgiving holiday that we had
here in the United States you can I
believe make a very good case that the
holiday marginalizes and ignores the
plight of Native American populations in
the United States who are of course
decimated by the arrival of European
settlers and to be clear I hate when
Thanksgiving events turn in the
direction of everybody going around the
table and saying what you're thankful
for I really don't like that but if
somebody made me answer that question
they said you know we're here on
Thanksgiving it is a holiday that is
connected to some really poor treatment
of native populations in the United
States but just let's go around the
table and say what we're thankful for
I would be able to come up with
something better than I'm thankful for
myself and all of the great things that
I'm doing I'd say I don't know I'm
thankful for family and friends or if I
wanted to be more civic minded I would
say I'm thankful for all the people
working hard to make the world a better
place for everybody I don't know I'd
come up with something like that Donald
Trump was asked what he's thankful for
and he said it's himself he's thankful
for himself and the really great
difference the tremendous difference
that he's making for the country he was
asked this mind you while former
President Barack Obama was volunteering
at a Chicago Food Bank serving people
Thanksgiving meals Donald Trump instead
spent his holiday at mar-a-lago his
Resort in Florida playing golf and
hanging out and here's Donald Trump's
answer about what he's thankful for this
Thanksgiving thank you all very much
we're having a great family and for
having made a tremendous difference in
this country I've made a tremendous
difference in the country this country
is so much stronger now than it was when
I took office that you wouldn't believe
it
and I mean you see it but so much
stronger that people can't even believe
it when I see foreign leaders they say
we cannot believe the difference in
strength between the United States now
and the United States two years ago made
a lot of progress thank you very much
in a sense maybe that's true like
foreign leaders don't believe the
difference he claims he made because he
didn't make it
this is beyond parity you can't parody
this anymore he's a caricature of
himself like he's putting the onion and
Saturday Night Live
out of business this reminds me of that
common job interview question what's
your biggest weakness what's your
biggest flaw a common job interview
question and sometimes people will
answer it with something that's kind of
bragging it's kind of like a pandering
answer my biggest flaw is I sometimes
work so hard that I ignore my family in
order to get my work done oh yeah what
terrible terrible flaw this is a version
of that but even crazier
like imagine Trump being asked what's
your biggest flaw he'd say you know I I
underestimate myself and how fantastic I
am at everything and that's something I
really have to contend with
there were right-wingers who complained
that Obama was making the presidency too
much about himself that Obama talked too
much about I where are they now pad
because that was nothing compared to
this level of delusion delusions of
grandeur and narcissism and and again
there's probably a grain of literal
truth like I assume pat that the other
world leaders he's talking about are
sitting around saying we don't believe
the change Donald Trump is claiming to
have achieved in the United States and
around the world because we don't think
he's achieved it it's such a total
softball question like can't you just
couch it in some different way can't you
say that you're thankful for the
hard-working people in your
administration who are contributing to
the lowest ever black unemployed
raid in the lowest ever Hispanic
unemployment rate and go down that list
of talking points that he always does
why can't he do that just once on
Thanksgiving it's an embarrassment and
it's going to take a really long time to
undo this mess and I was over the
weekend talking with some of my
relatives in Argentina and they've been
following they don't really follow so
much what goes on domestically but
they're very aware of the things Donald
Trump says and the actions that he takes
with regard to geopolitics and this
includes Russia this includes Saudi
Arabia this includes his buddy-buddy
relationship with the President of
Argentina Macri they they don't
understand how you have someone who is
totally unaware of the way that they are
seen as a joke around the world and I
think part of that is that he has
established a propaganda force within
his administration not externally for
him he gets these propaganda files twice
a day where he gets pictures of him
looking presidential or very alpha or
whatever positive headlines positive
lower thirds that are up on the screen
on Fox and Friends or whatever he
actually seems insulated from how the
entire world sees him and it's going to
take a long time to unto undo the damage
that this man has done to the country
and the worldwide reputation of the
United States and I know many trumpets
don't care about that they say David it
doesn't matter what the rest of the
world thinks about us because we're in
charge
we are the Alpha on the geopolitical
stage you really don't understand how
the world works in 2018 if that's your
perspective one of today's sponsors is
privacy calm slash Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things on
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below